CEO of tick tock showed up to Capitol
Hill yesterday to persuade lawmakers not
to ban the social media app and things
did not go particularly well do you
disagree with FBI director Ray and NSA
director nicosone when they said that
the CCP could have the capability to
manipulate data and send it to the
United States do you disagree with their
statement the statement says could so do
you disagree with that
no I don't disagree with that okay so it
is possible that the CCP
under the auspices of bite dance which
is your parent company which you get
paid from has the ability to manipulate
content that is being shared with 130
million Americans yes Congressman I
watch this one make sure I'm
understanding all these questions China
can spread highly targeted propaganda to
half the country they can also spy on us
collecting countless data to use against
us